yeah welcome to this video playing wide
against hmm yeah our penguin something
to do with penguins I don't know but
it's a queue here right okay we have our
tirage French Tara okay mmhmm yeah
probably probably this is the line I
don't I don't know ok player place
simple chassis hmm yeah
that shouldn't be too too bad for white
but how to set up Queen Queen be six
hours probably probably move
okay just protect you for if he goes
queen b 6i can I can also just go Quinn
to be three okay check all right
yeah Quinn a five-hour can can exchange
some stuff if I go we should be
frightfully a night before threatening
some silly discovery so let's check
exchange everything but this should be
an should be comfortable for white at
least I hope cut slightly better I've
got simply I've got more space on this
position this is always a bit of a
double-edged move because you in a way
also weaken your light square so that
may be a six-night a seven Bishop a for
Bishop b5 is coming into the play but I
don't want Knight a5 somewhere okay here
or YouTube probably hear a good idea for
black ears f6 and putting the bishop on
EA to h5 this kind of setup this is a
very um very harmonious ha ok I want to
make this night mobaile this is some way
i move the King to e3 protecting the d4
pawn we have this is no a middle game
anymore you can use your king to to do
some some job sir don't need you have it
hidden in the corner all the time yeah
yeah I think f6 is really something that
blacks should consider of course this is
not bad i mean i'm not i'm not saying
that again they can do that
who night ace mm-hmm
maybe the question is Roxy phi f is the
singles
guides difficult to prevent this but
should be five business oh this is
surprising why does he allow that not
that it's completely terrible but now I
have the idea at least them not sure
what is good but on Bishop b5 i can go
pee should be one keep the bishops on
the board
hmm you have this a three before
businesses some always tricky really oh
come on I need to need to be a bit
quicker let's play some good moves
quickly at least out there good thing
whether so win some space here so g 4 f
4g five would be nice in the long run ok
so I exchange it now taking on b5 is bad
yeah it is bad p what time yeah I don't
mind ok yeah ok this is a very one-sided
end game now so probably draw but i can
i can continue to play that
so how to continue
yeah probably a four a five if I'm able
to do that I should put this on the
board if he goes be five I have
something to attack on a six ok this is
now this is a concession I think it
would be better to take ok not sure not
sure this isn't so easy it looks it
looks like there's not much happening
but it is not easy at all ok let's go to
g5 and what would help me a king to age
four and then f5 this threatens f6 and I
hope this little thread ok let's just go
there at the end I want to play Bishop
c8 and win this pawn this is clear
and oh now I have an additional idea and
this is sacrificing would be five to let
the a pawn run okay can I do that now
even a six how does he stop the porn I
guess it doesn't basics and it's it's a
queen or as I recently hot in some
reason english speaking speaking a
commentary it's a girl it would be a
girl on a eight just just promoting but
it did it's tricky now it's it's really
tricky I'm not sure that black can
defend this of course this helped
enormously but I'm not sure at all I
mean f-5 s not easy to to handle let's
say he he moves the kingdom let's say
here I go f5 and you cannot take because
at the end i get the pawn this is why
you should have exchanged on a five
because then this bishop would actually
protect the poem and yeah what is he
supposed to do now you can just stay
basically it also shouldn't take here of
course is also not helping just stay
like this the question is do I have
something now I can I can go here even
then you go here it is is it winning
something like this yeah it is winning
actually like this come ok this is
Winningham
oh maybe not I was I was I was too quick
what a funny position I was thinking my
idea was taking here he takes with the
King it's it's all all easier because
that this at the end will will net oops
no we get the pawn but then he can go
here actually and I don't know how to to
do anything probably there is no way
very tricky so how do you win then
probably you don't you like just stays
you and I cannot take or maybe three if
you've got a suit so on here this is
possible maybe this is suks one yeah the
bishop cannot move it cannot take here
because of this again and you killed
where we should be five so black if
black moves the king yeah you go here
this is great this is just great and now
you cannot take here you must go here
and then here we were close to three
close to Zeus one very nice
going to 2g forum
no you must take and this is winning now
very nice yeah it's it's really it's
really a bit much this thick this space
this space this is Vantage but very
funny very funny endgame here yeah I
think one one very important point was
that he served you must take this he
must take it him just take this back on
here he must you must take this is very
important to have this Bishop protect
the phone I'm still better but maybe it
is a draw now I can do all those things
but it's not like those the sacrificial
ideas are gone and this is not such a
weak porn I mean white is better but
it's not easy to win probably you didn't
want to allow this possibility but you
can probably prevent that yeah very nice
end game at the end I hope you like it
thanks for watching